I have this dream of doing a spelling beyond steroids.
The contestants lineup facing a wheel labeled with a bunch of the world's
languages step write ups in that wheel and wherever it happens to land,
you have to read a word and write a word in that languages native writing
system.
Who,
who as a language nerd,
there's a lot that intimidates me about this spelling bee,
but I must confess there's one maniacally tuft written language that I really
hope this we'll never lands on.
I am excited.
Let's go through and list why each one of these scripts has some tricky letters.
And then at the end I will reveal to you the language with the world's scariest
spelling.
Number 10.
Wait,
what was that?
Uh,
come again.
This just in,
but apparently someone else already answered my question.
He swears that the worst script ever is Thai.
Hmm.
Really?
I mean,
I messed with Lao and Thai a few years ago.
Yeah,
they weren't super easy,
but tie.
Oh,
okay.
Here's his complaint.
See when a written language grows up and gets old.
The way people speak at changes over time,
but the way people write the language stays fossilized.
The result is historical spelling and ty has some blatant historical spelling.
Not only is Britain tie pretty old,
but even when it was new,
it modeled it's letters on Sanskrit,
so it inherited fossils from the getgo.
Ty has an Alpha syllabary with 44 consonant letters for riding,
just 21 consonant sounds plus vowels and tone marks,
plus a complicated way of figuring out how all of those letters work together to
tell you which tone to pronounce on which Val.
But I think this missed the point.
What is it about historical spelling that makes this script tough?
Consider two people.
First,
the reader,
won't you consider the reader a script is hard when I don't know which sound to
save for the letters I'm about to read and for the writer,
this script is hard if I don't know which letters to use for the sounds I want
to right now glance back at Thai.
There's something regular and predictable about it is especially for the reader.
We can sum it up in a not too long page on Wikipedia.
We can dust are hands off and set you loose on the language and you should do
fairly well.
In fact,
I think of Thai spelling is not too different from Greek in a way.
A bunch of letters come together to represent a smaller set of sounds.
It's that same many to one correspondence all also like tie some sounds
influenced others in predictable ways and yeah,
there aren't those tie tones to deal with,
but you're stuck with the Greek throne of system with its movable accents and
double accidents based on how pitch and val length used to work way back in
ancient Athens.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Don't fear time.
My friend look elsewhere.
It's got mountains,
it's got llamas.
It's got Buddhists talking.
Dama,
welcome to Tibet.
History tells us that Tibetans have this guy to thank for writing some tin
gumball.
Pardon the spelling there.
Sneak preview.
He brought kingdoms together to form the vast Tibetan empire.
He said,
hey guys,
we're Buddhist now and around the year six 30 he said,
a young minister to India to learn how to write.
What he brought back from India was a new Alpha syllabary just like tie.
They both emphasize consonants and surround them with Val's.
They both came with Buddhism,
so both have special conventions for transcribing sacred Sanskrit terms and
nowadays they both have to deal with tones and convoluted ways they weren't
designed to handle,
but written Tibetans is much,
much older.
Here's the basics.
You start with the base consonants with their builtin dummy vowels.
Then you learn to write vowels and was and rose in the years as little flags on
the consonants,
but it gets even more exotic.
Tibetan can stack consonants.
You can flip consonants.
It can clump together masses of consonants to build syllables that look like
this.
This is how to bet and spell these words and this is how they say them.
Did that sink in for you?
This is what people are reading.
This is what people are saying.
This tangled mess of consonants is why Yeti?
Yeah,
Jay is spelled bread.
Why the Tibetan languages,
even though it's really boosts and this the name for this cling on looking
beauty.
That is the Tibetan script.
How do you think it's pronounced?
And he clue time's up.
It's,
Ooh,
check.
Yeah.
If you think reading with these letters is hard,
you should try writing with them in Lhasa.
The sound's dupe might mean any of these words.
It might mean overflows,
accomplishes,
sows,
or even other forms of the verb accomplish like accomplished and we'll
accomplish.
But guess what?
Those are all spelled differently.
The puzzles don't stop.
Take two words with very similar spelling.
The one spelled grubs gets pronounced top and Greg's why that's wrong.
Give up yet.
Well,
there is some logic here.
Here's the deal.
Tibetan has core letters,
it has valves around those core letters and then outside letters.
And once you grasp that basic fact,
you can start figuring out which letters to ignore.
Like in this verb that looks like besides socks be as a prefix and the s is a
suffix.
So you can just concentrate on getting these middle letters right.
Suck maybe.
Okay.
And now you're thinking,
I get it.
It's the vowel and some other letters in the middle of the syllable I care
about.
I can just ignore everything else.
Damn [inaudible] to Ben.
Dangerous strategy there for two reasons.
Number one,
you need to know which letters not to ignore.
And reason number two,
we can't just drop letters and walk away like that.
Tibetan has a complicated relationship.
We're letters influenced the pronunciation of other letters,
meaning a silent letter can still change the way of their letters get
pronounced.
So the name of one of the major schools of Tibetan Buddhism is written like
this.
We might innocently cross out all of these sounds and say something like Ka
Queue,
but that Tibetan,
Ooh,
actually sounds like the German [inaudible] the air.
It acts that way because of the final d.
That's after it got cute.
Lucky you though.
Ooh,
Ooh.
Isn't the only vowel change that works this way and d isn't the only continent
that triggers it.
So yeah,
if you're dropping letters here,
you're influencing letters with ghosts,
letters,
and sometimes you're not even just dropping an influencing.
You're finding out that whole clusters of letters interact together to create
totally different sounds,
complex patterns.
It's all a complex patterns.
Now things ratch it up another notch.
When you put syllables together,
sometimes you'll find a letter that silent,
like say silent are before another consonant in the word [inaudible] so you
might cross it out and then forget about it just to have it suddenly pop out at
you when you smash it against another syllable,
like in this name,
to keep every little bit of this in mind when you run crying to your Tibetan
dictionary for help because the Tibetan idea of alphabetical order is not
organizing words by the first letter.
No,
no,
no.
They use that route,
letter,
wherever it happens to be.
Why do you do this to bed?
Science says that being a high altitude mountain people,
Tibetans have physiological advantages like increased blood flow to the brain.
Maybe they're spending that power on this bizarre writing system,
but honestly they did try to get rid of this bad spelling.
Karma.
Really Old Tibetan got a spelling reform in the year 800 and then,
well that that was it 1200 years ago.
Think of what's happened in 1200 years.
The Viking Age,
the Norman conquest of England,
everything ever written in tie the last end codices,
Chaucer,
Shakespeare with Tokugawa Shogun.
These are current events compared to the last time to bet changed its spelling.
That is some serious historical spelling and it's why when I'm standing there
watching the wheel clack clack clack around deciding my fate in that
multilingual spelling bee,
I really,
really hope that wheel doesn't land to bet.
Assuming we're thinking spelling means segmental scripts,
ones where we're matching letters to sounds,
but I'm going to step out of the bounds of this game show here because if we
color outside the Mandola lines to Betten isn't even the worst offender when it
comes to historical spelling and there's a written language that plays much
faster and looser with its symbols and expects way more readers and writers than
Tibetans ever could.
Thanks for joining me and my spelling bee.
I really liked having you here.
Stick around and subscribed for language Tibetan on.